- The night...
a shadowy world
that hides more than
half the animals on our planet.
(thunder rumbles)
Until now, cameras only offered
a glimpse into their lives.
(trumpets)
- But, with next generation technology,
we can see the night...
(hyena chuckles)
(thunder crashes)
- ...as clear as day.
♪ In the dead of night ♪
♪ Strange things happen ♪
♪ Better hold on tight ♪
- Filming just by the light of the moon
will test the crew to their limits.
- Currently stuck in the ice.
- To capture the lives of animals,
and their nocturnal journeys, in color.
- I think the book on jaguar behavior
is being written right here.
- So nice to see what they do at night.
It's so special.
- It turns us humans...
into nocturnal animals.
(snarls)
♪ In the dead of night ♪
♪ Strange things happen ♪
♪ The world goes cold ♪
- Discover Earth's last true wilderness.
♪ Better hold on tight ♪
- The night.
♪ In the dead of night ♪
♪ Strange things happen ♪
♪ Better hold on tight ♪